العقيد معمر القذافي
لا يرحل دون أن يترك شيئا لشعبه
، ولا يرحل دون وصية،
وفي الحقيقة فالعقيد لم يرحل ألا وقد حقق للشعب الليبي
مالم يحققه قائدا من قبله وأكمل مسيرة شيخ المجاهدين عمر المختار،
العقيد الذي جعل ليبيا تقارع كبريات الدول اسما وسيادة،
العقيد الذي هدد أمريكا وأخاف إيطاليا،
هل يرحل كمن قبله أو كعابر سبيل؟
لا فالعقيد نعم قد رحل ولكنه ترك وصية لشعبه العزيز
وكان متأكدا إذا نُفذت هذه الوصية فإن الشعب سيكون بخير،
كان العقيد يعلم إلى أين ستؤول الأوضاع بشعبه
لذلك ترك لهم وصية، فيا ترى ماذا قال العقيد في وصيته،،
جاء نص وصية القذافي كالتالي:
• ( بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم”
كل نفس ذائقة الموت وإنما توفون أجوركم يوم القيامة”.
• هذه وصيتي
أنا معمر بن محمد بن عبد السلام بن حُميد بن أبومنيار
بن حُميد بن نايل القُحصي القذافي.
• أشهد أن لا إله إلا الله وأن محمدا رسول الله عليه الصلاة والسلام
وأموت على عقيدة أهل السنة والجماعة.
• وأوصي بما يأتي:
• – أن لا أُغسّل، وأن أدفن وفق تعاليم الشريعة الإسلامية
وفي ثيابي التي أموت فيها.
• – أن أُدفن في مقبرة سرت إلى جوار قومي وأهلي
• – أن تُعامل عائلتي وخاصة نساءها وأطفالها معاملة حسنة.
• – أن يحافظ الشعب الليبي على هويته وعلى منجزاته وتاريخه
وصورة أجداده وأبطاله المشرفة
وأن لا يسلّم في تضحيات أحراره وأخياره.
• – أن تستمر مقاومة أي عدوان أجنبي
تتعرض له الجماهيرية الآن أو غدا وعلى الدوام
أن يثق الأحرار في الجماهيرية والعالم
أننا كنا نستطيع المتاجرة بقضيتنا
والحصول على حياة شخصية آمنة ومستقرة
وجاءتنا عروش كثيرة، ولكننا اخترنا أن نكون في المواجهة
واجبا وشرفا، وحتى إذا لم ننتصر عاجلا
فإننا سنعطي درسا تنتصر به الأجيال التي ستأتي،
لأن اختيار الوطن هو البطولة وبيع الوطن هو الخيانة
التي لن يستطيع التاريخ أن يكتب غيرها مهما حاولوا تزويره
• – أن يبلّغ سلامي إلى عائلتي فردا فردا وإلى أوفياء الجماهيرية
وإلى كل أوفياء العالم الذين ساندونا ولو بقلوبهم.
• والسلام عليكم جميعا
• معمر بن محمد القذافي)...
الشعب الليبي يعيش حالة من الفوضى،
وطريقم للاستقرار يمر من تنفيذ وصية قائدهم السابق،
فهل يعود الليبيون إلى رشدهم ويمضوا وفق إرشادات العقيد؟،
وبماذا شعر الليبيون عند قراءة وصية العقيد؟
وسوف نضع لكم المصادر أسفل هذا الفيديو ....